hola pues en este informe el presidente
ha destacado
siete récord históricos en lo que va de
su administración entre ellos el aumento
al salario mínimo que ha sido de 44 por
ciento algo no visto en tres décadas así
como la inversión extranjera el índice
de la bolsa de valores las reservas del
banco de méxico y la no el no aumento de
la deuda pública y de la devaluación del
peso la no devaluación asimismo ha
señalado que en materia de seguridad
únicamente tres delitos de los 11 de
alto impacto no han tenido una reducción
se trata del feminicidio que ha tenido
un alza así como de la extorsión y el
robo al transporte público no obstante
dijo que en el tema de homicidios hay
una ligera tendencia a la baja y ya se
frenó está esta tendencia alcista que
había en síntesis señaló que se ha
cumplido 98 de los 100 compromisos que
tenía al inicio de su administración y
quedan pendiente únicamente la
descentralización de la administración
pública así como conocer lo que
verdaderamente ocurrió en el caso de los
estudiantes desaparecidos de ayotzinapa
en guerrero destacó que la economía
según en la mayoría de los indicadores
crecerá 6% el próximo año y que se ha
frenado la tendencia privatizadora sobre
todo en el sector energético para acabar
con lo que dijo ha sido la gran farsa
neoliberal